I hate intros attack on Titan season 1
we kicked things off in the year 8 145
but the main character ad in iaeger
having a bad dream an uncontested waifu
mikasa ackerman there to point out that
he's correct when they head back to town
they run into any cops in Hans who were
drinking on the job
paedon has clearly never tried drinking
on the job before so he gets upset but
at least they're not killing minorities
now we are introduced to a poor boy
named odd Amin who nearly died to an
overexposure of highly concentrated beta
characteristics oh by the way the cost
of time shows up cakes a hole in the
wall and a Titan kills Evans mom yeah
episode 2 realize in the district his
lost soldiers have to close wall Maria
this cues the introduction of the
armored Titan who breaks through the
wall and lets tines into the first major
territory so now that wall Maria is
compromised refugees have to fall back
even further to wall rows we get a quick
look at evidence that who's heading back
from a trip inside of wall brows there
isn't enough food to support the
overflow of refugees coming from wall
Maria with food supply Solo in the year
846 the central government sends 250,000
refugees including Ottomans grandfather
to retake wall Maria we're all about a
hundred died this was essentially a
suicide mission in order to clear up
food for the remaining population all
three agree on going to military
training and end up joining training
unit 104 led by Keith Sharda theis
episode 3 aka the side character intro
episode we come in with the training of
the new recruits where we are introduced
to some of the temporary side characters
such as Thomas Wagner and Mina Carolina
John Kirsten also gets his first scene
where he's headed by for admitting to
join he said that he could live in the
safety of the inner walls marco bott
tends to suck up with his answers and
gets shut down
connie springer forgets why Handa salute
with so he gets a gentle reminder right
before sasha pedasi becomes an instant
legend / meme and then is forced to run
all day
potato girl helps introduce konista lens
while she brings her some food since
she's been running all day as well as
Conesus Randy Mia the next challenge is
the 3d maneuver gear aptitude training
test which when Castle one shots while
daydreaming about Evan on the opposite
end of the spectrum eden fails miserably
while dave dreaming about killing titans
edit starts asking everybody for tips
including grinder bran and battle to
virtue instead get a sad story it turns
out he didn't actually need the advice
he had faulty equipment which is why he
was struggling so when they fixed that
he was a natural and finally passes the
aptitude test the episode for Jabba had
two years after enlisting to the Year
850 and we get some new character
introductions including Annie leonhart
everyone is still in training and
continuing to work hard to improve the
military structured into three branches
the garrison defending
Walsall Recon Corps which editon is
shooting for who go outside the walls
and fight the Titans and finally the
Military Police Brigade who live inside
the inner walls and work under the king
everyone runs into Hans again for the
first time since they left for training
clones apologizes to Adam for not being
able to save his mother and Adam
forgives him finally out of training in
five years after his mother's death Eden
is feeling as confident as ever
which is the proper time to keep the
second appearance at the colossal Titan
who kicks a hole through the district
wall Yepez owed five Evan goes toe to
toe costs time by himself
I don't know what everybody else was
doing but when he sees an opening to hit
the vital on his neck the tyent releases
steam and disappears before he could
land the strike even though the colossal
Titan is gone the wall is still breached
so residents of the district are forced
to evacuate back to wall rows soldiers
are sent out with the objective of
holding off the tines until the
evacuation is complete
Adam is assigned to squad 34 along with
ottoman thomas amina who get order to
aid the frontline right as they're
getting into the fight they run into an
abnormal an Thomas's guild heaven goes
into a rage and rushes to kill the time
and avenged on us but while heading
there he gets clipped out of midair and
loses his leg the squad goes to help him
but Mina's thrown into a wall and killed
by another Titan how to be Mossad mean
and is about to be eaten so Adam has to
throw him to safety but while saving him
he loses his arm and is eaten by the
titan episode 6 you me at accounting
increase to find out Amin who's in
typical meltdown mode Timo Reeves gets
his cart stuck in wall rows which is why
the evacuation is going so slowly
because asset threatened him to get the
evacuation back on track we get some
lore on Mikasa and how her and admin
came to know each other so men come to
abduct her and her mother to sell
because they're both oriental which is a
very rare the man had only planned on
killing the father but in the heat of
the moment they end up killing both
parents how does dad was a doctor who
was heading to their house with a tan
and sees the bodies since she's missing
ed and goes looking for her and kills
two of the men and is attacked by the
third he somehow manages to monologue
with a grown man choking the life out of
him to convince Mikasa to fight back she
has a sudden burst of power of some sort
and then kills the third man with her
parents dead and his dad takes her in
and Edden gives her his scarf which is
why she's always wearing it back to the
president Mikasa defies orders to go 8th
the second line hey episode 7 30 orders
given to the remaining soldiers but they
are out of gas because the support
squads who were supposed to be bringing
them gas for the maneuver gear or pin
down inside of HQ we got to reach to
some of the survivors who point her to
our mean I don't mean explains what
happened to that man and how he
sacrificed himself to save him because
it was surprisingly calm hearing this
news antics controlled the situation to
command them on what to do next
however when heading to the HQ Mikasa
show sign says she is distraught at the
loss of edit she burns through her gas
too quickly and crashes leaving her
stranded on ground level while being
approached by a tie and she feels like
she's given up on living but something
inside her forces her to take action to
avoid death she
confused as to why she's still trying to
survive when she was ready to die a
second ago and now normal tide shows up
in cheap sauce the time that was after
her then curb stomps the time to death
given Connie and I to mean the chance to
grab Picasa and get her to safety
episode 8 autumn ian is still dead way
but comes up with a fairly predictable
plan to use the abnormal time to attack
the other Titans at HQ because he goes
to help clear path through the abnormal
Titan in an attempt to lure him to HQ
well that's happening John who was
supposed to go to the inner walls in
safety in one day struggles to lead in
Mikasa stead but eventually makes it at
HQ with a handful of survivors John
finds some of the supply squad cowering
under a desk and loses it because of all
the lives they cost because of
successfully lures the abnormal just in
time to save them from approaching
Titans while the abnormal fights outside
the other still need to secure the
storeroom with the canisters I'd mean
who needs some desperate relevancy and
the story comes up with another rather
stale plan that is portrayed as this
mind-blowing Epiphany the use of
soldiers will blind the Titans with guns
while real fighters go for the vitals
before they can reject the tension is
immense as they wait for tines to get as
close as possible and all I can think is
why would you give a demean a gun the
attack succeeds and they can finally
retreat back to wall rows but before
they do they notice that the abnormal is
being pinned down and eaten by Titans
they contemplate helping you but before
they can the Titan who killed Thomas
shows up the abnormal goes into rage and
pushes itself to its limits killing the
Titan and avenging Thomas after that it
collapses the neck pops open like a
cockpit and Edden makes his dramatic
reappearance
episode 9 rewind to earlier that day
before the attack the Recon Corps had
left on a mission which is why the
attack was so much more devastating than
it should have been
during the mission they start to realize
that the Titans are heading toward the
city so they start heading back fearing
the worst
yeah we jumped ahead just a bit to where
Aaron had been eaten by the time while
saving baby boy well he's in the tiny
stomach he yells at the Titans but just
before he turns into the abnormal time
that helped secure HQ finally we jump
back to the present we're at an ottoman
and Mikasa are held at gunpoint by the
soldiers inside of wall Bros a band that
just come to and has no recollection of
changing into a Titan so he's confused
as to why they're in this situation
captain keeps watermen is leading the
interrogation but is terrified and isn't
satisfied with the answers they've been
providing so he prepares a signal
artillery to kill all three of them in a
panic Mikasa prepares to escape over the
wall while grabbing at it while doing
this I didn't seize the key that his dad
gave him hanging around his neck in
memories he had forgotten started coming
back of his dad injecting him with the
mysterious hiraman telling him that he
needs to learn to control this power and
take back wall Maria so that he can get
to his dad's basement
this means that hadn't had come into
contact with his dad after the first
attack and the death of his mom five
years ago protect me cos I not mean he
bites his hand in turns partway into a
Titan at least enough to stop the blast
from killing everybody
episode 10 after all of his hard work I
don't mean had finally achieved its
lifelong goal of being inside about
they decide to have aadmi and speak on
their behalf and convince he captain
that they aren't a threat he tries
explaining that because the other Titans
had attacked him in his sign form he's
obviously considered an enemy said they
should trust him and use his powers to
retake wall Maria the captain Speirs did
great for him to listen to logic at this
point so he prepares to launch a second
attack when he stopped by Pixies who was
the superior and says he wants to hear
him out he decides to give it those
three of them protection Nevadan agrees
to use this time for him to move a
boulder in front of the opening in trust
district wall to stop the flow times and
retake the district episode eleven
pixies explains his plan to all the
soldiers claiming that Adhan is actually
a military science subject who can turn
into a Tyne and that they're going to
use him to close the opening in the wall
the planets that have a small team of
elites escort him and protect him while
he's moving the boulder wall a decoy
team is sent out to draw tiles away from
the boulder to minimize resistance eden
reaches the boulder and transforms while
Mikasa is standing near but she realizes
something is wrong and Evan suddenly
attacks Mikasa II episode 12 because it
dodges a dense attacks and tries talking
to him accidentally initiating the blood
children's game why are you hitting
yourself which knocks a ding and is
Diane unconscious science start closing
in on the elite so Ian who was in charge
or to see elites to fight the incoming
Titans and protect added I don't mean he
was on the decoy team gets that I mean
he costly explains that he's knocked out
and can't control the time maybe he's
awake adding up I don't mean stabs
through the Titans neck to injure add in
forcing him to wake up evidence tying
jolts and pain have to Adam eats ABS and
through the Orang but he's hallucinating
that he's with his family had been
finally breaks from his hallucination
thanks to beta boy and his Titan wakes
up yepez owed 13 I didn't had regained
control of his Titan and starts carrying
the boulder to the opening in the wall
well protecting amitabh he's crushed by
one ian is decapitated comunion leaving
the hottie cuz the only Lea who survives
while they're fighting at and
successfully blocks the opening
signalling the first victory for
Humanity against the Titans oh and John
say character friend Marco Eden is held
in a cell by the military police in
question by Commander Edwin and Captain
Levi he says that he wants to join the
Recon Corps and eradicate the Tiny's
this convinces Levi and he says that
he's gonna take responsibility for added
he episode 14 although Levi said that he
was gonna take a turn under his
responsibility he's still being held by
the military police word is getting
around about the tyne ally the military
police who live inside a wall Cena once
you eliminate Adam because of the rumors
spreading about him adding a revolt
against the inner wall because of the
split decision between the military
police and the Recon Corps a military
tribunal scheduled where Eden's fate
will be decided commander in chief daddy
exactly is given the responsibility of
deciding at its fate in front of a court
I'm Zoe makes her first appearance while
creeping on ed and when she comes to
escort him to the court both sides state
their case and it isn't looking good for
Evan as people are being swayed by the
military police
that's one head and being yet and it's
like wait I feel a monologue coming on
and pops off on all the attendees Henry
basa this captain Levi gives him the yes
kicking of century but sends the message
say he is capable and ready of keeping
it in under control commander edwin
suggests taking out an on an expedition
to see if he really is willing to help
them which is enough to convince that
lisa Edden is released to the recon
corps
episode 15 adam is release and the
movement of the former recon corps HQ
which is a castle inside of wall ropes
we get a couple of new faces who are on
the special ops squad or levi squad levi
goes into his nitori's climbing mode
while birthing an internet meme the rest
of the episode is pretty filler as
concha shows up and wants add-in to help
out with two times a captured while Bri
taking troske but when they go to
perform the experience both of the times
have been killed through the night
apparently it was more than one soldier
with 3d maneuver gear but nobody knows
who the episode 16 we come in with
inspections of recruits and their gear
trying to find the ones responsible for
killing the tines who are in captivity
in light of the loss of his friend Marco
John thinks back to some of the things
that Marco said to him and ends up
deciding to join the Recon Corps Eddin
is finally reunited with beta boy in
Mikasa where he learns that John joined
as well and also about Markos death
Madoka Lucinda the last scene is the
Recon Corps officially launching the
57th expedition episode 17 during the
expedition Ottoman and his squad leader
Nez come into contact with an abnormal
this female teen appears to be
intelligent so when Nessa is mango for
her vital she quickly kills both of them
I don't mean this now alone gets knocked
off his horse by the time and is
helpless the tide pulls back his hoe to
get a good look at his face and then
lets him live oughta mean is soon
reunited with Ryder and John and they
pursue the female teen who they came to
the conclusion is a human controlling
the Titan like edit who three of them
attempt to injure her to prevent her
from reaching yet and who was her
presumed goal Reiner nearly dies but
they all make it out alive at least
unting her progress she's last seen
running toward the center rear we're
adding a supposably at episode 18 the
formation runs into a forest of large
trees the modal formation goes through
the forest while the side formations go
around the outside a dream is confused
as to why they're riding through the
forest which hinders their ability to
protect the wagons
what do you guess Levi he receives no
answer and realizes that it's not just
him but the whole squad is in the dark
and having doubts about what exactly is
going on the female time shows herself
and engages soldiers while trying to
reach out it episode 19
the female time is right behind them but
Levi tells them to keep going which pays
off because just ahead was an ambush
that Edwin had set up to capture the
female Titan Levi heads back to me with
that one and find out he's in the Tyne
while Levi squad and Edden go ahead
without him
episode 20 rebuy squad discussed why
they didn't know about the ambush and
come to the conclusion that there must
be a spy in the army attempts to extract
the person inside the Titan fail because
it can harden the skin preventing
strikes from being effective it releases
a cry for help and Titans converge from
all sides the female tions body is eaten
by the Titans but there's no proof that
whoever was inside was killed all the
squads get the retreat order and start
back whoever was in the female Titan
disguises themselves as a recon corps
member and shoots off a green smoke fire
think again sleeve by the squad set up
their own flare revealing their position
mystery character uses 3d maneuver gear
to attack and kill goo thir in the last
scene episode 21 Levi's squad in editing
continue running to get ad into safety
from the disguised assailant who turns
back into the female Titan the wrist of
the Levi's squad members are killed by
the female Titan so Eden loses it and
transforms to fight this [ __ ] throws a
haymaker into the ground twice breaking
both of his arms once that heals he gets
his face kicked in half with the Stein
disable deaden is abducted and because
he comes in at the perfect time to see
this because of pursues and flexes but
is intercepted by Levi who tells her to
follow the time because she's probably
getting tired episode 22 way behind me
cos are still in pursuit of the female
Titan and eventually fired
look I'm not gay I'm not but Levi makes
my heart beat like I am he bounces back
and cuts up in the Titans mouth
revealing Eden retrieve Sam and retreats
the recon corps is under heavy scrutiny
by the public when they return and it's
decided the evidence gonna be handed
over to the military police yeah but so
23 back in wall say no we go over to
Annie who's now a member of the military
police there's a relatively point in the
side story about a guy named Marla who
wants to stop corruption he sees
corruption happening tries to stop it
and get smacked around while heading
back someone calls to Annie so she goes
to investigate and finds beta boy there
explains that they're planning on
executing Atta and he wants her help to
get ed in free they move through the
city using John as a decoy in his place
everything is going smoothly until they
get to the abandoned underground city
that they're gonna use to escape and
that's when Annie refuses to go inside
she realizes that there hasn't been any
people nearby for a long time and knows
something is up jump back just Ben I
don't mean had recognized that Annie had
Markos 3d here during the inspections
because he worked on it with him and
recognized the dings and scratches on it
Marko was John's friend who mysteriously
died on the decoy team moving the bulls
are in troske
because it doesn't beat around the bush
and just accuses her outright of being
the female teen she has a completely
normal reaction to this accusation and
then tries to bite her hand
how did me pops of noise grenade
signaling nearby soldiers to subdue her
they succeeded in preventing the by but
she's wearing a ring that she can use to
help her transform Yepez o24 they have
to switch to plan B which is edit
transforming into a sign for him to
fight Annie but even though he injures
himself he can't transform we get a
quick flashback of all the things they
discovered that pointing to Anna being
the tiny because he goes fully on today
when she suspects that he can't
transform cos he has feelings for Annie
we can't stay in the tunnels oh so
Mikasa and I don't mean have to run as a
distraction to give Evan a chance to
escape but as they do a dennis crushed
by debris soldiers try to stop Annie and
Mikasa gets knocked out of the fight and
finally I didn't transforms throwing a
sucker punch on a girl to kick off the
final fight episode 25 Sunday school
gets out early while Eden and Annie go
head-to-head
Paden gets manhandled and looks like
he's out of it after that severe beat
down but that reversed she was classy
Excel he starts messing her up so she
tries to climb the wall to safety Mikasa
isn't having that though and cuts off
her fingers preventing her escape
followed by an edgy one-liner edding
goes to extract annie from the titan
boat when he sees her he freezes giving
a me the chance to preserve herself
inside the Titans hardened skin all the
attempts I make to get to her fail hany
gonna add in to the military police is
put on hold in light of the events after
that annie has moved underground for
safekeeping last seen after the ending
credits reveals that during the fight
between the Titans part of all Sina was
damaged and pieces break off revealing a
face of a Titan inside the wall